Next, we love to try new things at this desk
and give them our honest on-the-spot reviews
because this is Drew's Reviews.
(audience cheering)
And, today, we have a special guest reviewer
joining us right here in the audience.
It's our friend, Florence.
Hi, Florence.
Hi, Drew, hi, Ross.
How are you?
Hi, Florence.
So cute.
Does anyone ever call you Flo?
All the time.
Do you like it?
Yes.
Like is that a yes
as in like, "I tolerate it" or "I'm connected"?
You know, family and friends will call me Flo.
If you don't know me, please call me Florence.
Ha!
That's what I'm looking for, honesty.
All right, Rossy, what's up first?
All right, well, Florence,
we're start with a suggestion from our own Drew Barrymore.
Yeah, this one caught Drew's eye.
She brought it here to the desk.
And "Mashed" reports there's a new cereal in town
and it's made of tiny, little pastries,
and it's called Mini Croissant cereal.
That's right.
Mhmm.
And this took off on TikTok by Chef Christine Wijaya.
And you take store-brought croissants.
You just take the dough
and cut it into little, tiny triangles.
And then, you bake your own tiny croissants.
And then, cover it in a mixture
of Nutella and Biscoff cookie butter,
and add your milk.
And we've got some freshly-baked version here
from a bakery in Brooklyn called L'Appartement 4F.
And these are made with their fresh croissant dough
dipped in cinnamon syrup.
And you guys, Florence,
Drew, what do you think?
Florence,
tell us what you think.
They're like just like croissants.
They're not too sweet.
That's not bad, I don't like sweet cereal,
and that's not too sweet.
This is good.
I would eat this again.
Yeah.
(audience clapping)
I would eat it again.
All right, Rossy?
Okay, what I love about this is,
as my good friend, Florence, said,
there's not too much sweetness
and it's flaky like a croissant.
You know those layers that taste
like they're filled with butter.
I mean, Florence, it's time to rate it.
What out of five stars do you give it?
A four.
(Ross laughing)
I love Florence.
Florence, you won't give a five for anything, right?
It's gotta be extraordinary.
It's gotta be fantastic.
It's gotta be boom!
You get a five.
(audience clapping)
You know.
To translate for Florence, a four is really high.
Really high.
Yeah, it is.
I'm gonna give this a 4 1/2.
Because I think maybe it could use
just a little more sweetness with it.
Mhmm, some people like it sweeter, yeah, but.
You know, with cinnamon sugar or something.
It's cool.
I'm gonna give it a five.
Understood.
(audience clapping)
Five, five, five, five.
Rossy, what's next?
All right, so next up, this comes from Anne Hopper.
Hi, Anne, thanks for the suggestion.
It's a new cleaning solution for your home.
Have you ever wished you could turn your feet
into two giant Swiffers
and just skate around collecting dust?
Well, now you can with Mop Slippers, a pack of five!
Yes!
Wow!
They fit on with your shoes.
But Drew Barrymore is modeling them right now.
Take a look at that.
Woo! (clapping)
Nice.
They come in a pack of five.
They're reusable, they're $15.
When you're done, you can just throw 'em in the wash.
Florence, you wanna try them on?
Oh, I like your purple ones.
Thank you.
Oh, yes, we all have different colors!
Okay.
Wow, Florence.
Oh, but look.
Florence, I like your color.
Oh, but look, we could have a mopping party.
Invite some people over to your house.
Put the shoes on.
Say, "Hey, listen, come on in
and put on these new shoes."
Spray the floor, and then go.
Yeah!
Oh, that's good.
Let's go dance around
and spray the floor.
Yes, spray the floor!
That's a great idea, Florence.
Yeah, spray the floor
and let them dance around on your floor,
you know.
Yeah.
(audience clapping)
This is very satisfying.
This is why I feel like
doing that ice skating formation.
I like 'em.
You had me at spray the floors.
Ross, ratings?
Yeah.
These are a five out of five for me.
These are a lot of fun.
I would do this around the house.
Florence?
Okay, you can have a 4 1/2 here.
Ooh!
Whoa!
That's huge!
Florence, that's the highest rating you've ever given.
I mean, these are easy if you wanna mop your floors.
But, listen, invite people over and let them do it for you.
Florence, I was gonna give it a four.
But when you said spray first, and then like move,
I'm gonna go 4 1/2
and meet you where you're at.
Yes, yes.
Thank you, Florence.
I love you.
(upbeat music)